One night, a servant found the old king had
died in his sleep and ran to inform Queen
Alicent.
Protocol dictated that the bells would be
rung and a raven sent to Dragonstone to summon
the heir, Princess Rhaenyra, for her coronation.
But Alicent had other plans.
Once she saw her dead husband's body, she
sealed the room and had the servant thrown
into the Black Cells to ensure his silence.
At the hour of the owl, the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard, Ser Criston Cole, summoned
the small council to inform them of the king's
death.
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King and
father to Queen Alicent, demanded that the
succession be settled immediately.
The decrepit old men of the small council
were confused; the succession was settled
in their minds.
The old king had forced the lords of Westeros
to swear fealty to Princess Rhaenyra as his
heir.
But Ser Criston Cole rightly pointed out that
a son comes before a daughter.
The council argued until dawn when the Master
of Coin finally stood up and declared he would
have no part of treason.
Ser Criston Cole wisely opened his throat
with a dagger, ending the debate.
None were more surprised to hear of Prince
Aegon's succession than Prince Aegon himself.
At first, the fool rejected the crown, but
his mother pointed out that his sister Rhaenyra
would return such loyalty by taking his head.
As the old king's trueborn son, he'd always
be a threat.
Aegon relented.
He was crowned in the Dragonpit, and his wife
and sister Helaena became queen.
His brother Aemondflew off to win over the
few great lords whose support Aegon didn't
already have.
The banner of the gold dragon flew over King's
Landing and the Red Keep as Aegon, Second
of His Name, ascended the Iron Throne.
He would not sit it long.